guten tag allzu leicht vergessen wir wie
fragil und bedroht die freiheit einer
offenen gesellschaft ist aus diesem
grund hat sich mein heutiger gast die
historikerin und publizistin applebaum
der geschichte der unfreiheit gewidmet
insbesondere spaniens totalitarismus
sein erbe prägt die weltpolitik bis
heute von putins russland über den krieg
in der ukraine ja bis zur
präsidentschaft der sie trumps brennende
themen die wir heute genauer erläutern
wollen applebaum herzlich willkommen
frau will bauen lassen sich das mit
einem positiven akzent beginnen welches
ereignis der inneren weltgeschichte hat
ihnen denn in den letzten wochen am
meisten hoffnungen gemacht
ich denke in einigen europäischen
namentlich osteuropäischen ländern sehen
wir die anfänge einer anti
populistischen gegenreaktion
die intelligente ist als die frühere es
gibt neue partei konfigurationen die
grünen und die liberalen beginnen zu
verstehen dass sie bezüglich ihrer
politik mehr farbe bekennen müssen
das sieht man ansatzweise in der schweiz
in spanien polen in der slowakei
es ist interessant dass in diesem
zusammenhang nicht die ukraine erwähnen
dort gab es eine freie wahl einen
friedlichen machtübergang und einen
neuen überraschungs präsidenten
wolodimir zielinski was halten sie von
diesem neuen präsidenten
es ist ein wenig früh etwas über ihn zu
sagen dass interessante das berühmte am
see lenski ist interessant ist dass er
eine kampagne als fiktive figur vierte
seine wahlkampagne war seine
fernsehserie er ist komiker schauspieler
und produzent und seine fernseh serie
handelt von einem geschichtslehrer aus
der ukrainischen provinz der unverhofft
zum präsidenten gewählt rückt dann mit
korruption konfrontiert wird
interessanterweise sind die werte die in
dieser sendung vermittelt werden sie
ansprechend die geschichtslehrer ist
demokrat
er glaubt an bildung und ist gegen
korruption er ist ein mann des volkes
ein normaler bürger
scheint daher sehr vielen gewöhnlichen
kran aus dem herzen zu sprechen
verwirrend ist dass wir keine ahnung
haben ob die figur die ihr im fernsehen
spielt auch seinem tatsächlichen wesen
und spricht also glauben sie dass der
fiktionalen charakter im prinzip dass es
was gewählt wurde oder das was dieser
fiktionalen charakter durchaus aber es
wirkt ein bisschen unverantwortlich ein
land im krieg seit fünf jahren wehrt
einen menschen der keinerlei erfahrung
hat von dem man auch gar nicht weiß
wofür steht man könnte sagen dass es gar
nicht demokratie das ist zynismus das
ist einfach nur eine wahl gegen jemanden
und nicht für jemanden ich würde sagen
das trifft teilweise zu es war eine wahl
gegen borussia und gegen die verbreitete
meinung die ukraine werde nur von
korrupten oligarchen dominiert doch wie
gesagt so bizarres klingt die werte die
diese fernsehserie vertritt unsere
lenski mit seiner figur verkörpert sind
ansprechen dieser kleine mann der für
menschenrechte oder besser für
gerechtigkeit kämpft und sich eine
egalitäre und bessere gesellschaft
wünscht das ist keine unattraktive
botschaft also die werte demokratie in
der ukraine bejaht in form von zellen
ski es ist ein land das seit fünf jahren
krieg ist und über dasselbe über das wir
hier in mitteleuropa ganz wenig wissen
es wird auch ganz wenig berichtet man
kann eigentlich von einem konstanten
desinteresse an diesem konflikt sprechen
was sind die gründe dieses desinteresse
sehen sie bis vor kurzem bis 19 91 war
die ukraine kein unabhängiger staat
die leute sahen sie als teil russlands
und wussten nicht dass sie eine eigene
identität und sprache besitzt es gibt
also eine verständliche erklärung für
dieses desinteresse in jüngerer zeit da
gebe ich ihnen recht als 2014 der krieg
ausbrach waren die medien voll davon
doch das interesse ließ nach ich denke
dieses desinteresse und das mangelnde
verständnis widerspiegeln auch das
schlechte gewissen des westens warum
gibt es in der ukraine und auch in
russland korrupte oligarchen unter
anderem weil westliche banken und
westliche finanzinstitute dies zulassen
wir waschen ihr geld wir lassen zu dass
diese illegalen bei uns leben nicht weit
von diesem fernsehstudio entfernt
natürlich auch in der schweiz
wir sind so stolz auf unsere nicht
korrupten sauberen gesellschaften aber
tatsächlich tätigen wir diese
schmutzigen geschäfte im etat auf den
finanzmärkten im internet und
ermöglichen damit diese dinge also
sozusagen einer verdrängte mit
verantwortung die in die sind
desinteresse mitspielt aber vielleicht
auch eine art militärischer
hilflosigkeit wenn man sagt was sollen
wir schon tun
auf diese frage hätte ich ihnen vor ein
paar jahren mehrere antworten geben
können und auch jetzt gibt es
unterschiedliche antworten
heute haben wir ganz klar ein interesse
daran den ukrainischen staates aufrecht
zu erhalten und ihm zu helfen sich zu
verteidigen
wie die freien westlichen gesellschaften
wir europäer wenn sie so wollen
es ist in unserem interesse dass es
zwischen der europäischen union und
russland einen großen staat gibt der
europäisch ist oder zumindest die
demokratie anstrebt das verändert die
machtverhältnisse was gut ist für ruhig
für den handel für das business
die ukraine wird ein guter nachbar
europa sein wenn sie sich weiter in
diese richtung entwickelt geopolitische
wirtschaftlich gesehen ist ließ sie in
unserem interesse weil viele menschen
gar nicht genau wissen was dort passiert
haben einen kleinen einspieler
vorbereitet über die lage die jetzt
herrscht und es gab eine neue aktion
eine neue maßnahme nämlich präsident
putin hat den besetzten gebieten
gebieten der ukraine vorgeschlagenen
einwohnern die pässe von russland
annehmen zu können wir schauen uns das
kurzem ein spieler an
das russische dekret gilt für die
selbsternannten republiken donetsk und
lugansk im osten der ukraine und damit
für über drei millionen bürger in einem
erleichterten dreimonatigen prozedere
können sie seit gestern russische
staatsbürger werden
das ist eine präsident lose einmischung
russlands in die inneren angelegenheiten
eines unabhängigen staates
es ist eine brutale verletzung der
ukrainischen souveränität und
territorialen integrität in den regionen
donetsk und lugansk mit den
gleichnamigen hauptstädten wird seit
fünf jahren gekämpft den rot schraffiert
bereich betrachten separatisten seither
als unabhängige republik immer wieder
flammen die kämpfe auf obwohl bereits
vor vier jahren im minsker abkommen eine
waffenruhe vereinbart wurde
die beobachtungs mission der osze meldet
fast täglich verstöße von beiden seiten
nun mit seinem entscheid setzt wladimir
putin eine eskalation des konflikts im
osten der ukraine tatsächlich aufs spiel
im besten fall bleibt die massive
vergabe der russischen presse lediglich
eine strategie auf dem papier im kreml
um kiew in zugzwang zu bringen
im schlechtesten fall jedoch führt die
massive vergabe von russischen pässen zu
einer schleichenden annexion der gebiete
um dann jetzt kommt hans eine
tatsächliche eskalation des konflikts im
osten der ukraine kann sich russland
langfristig jedoch nicht leisten weder
politisch noch finanziell 15 milliarden
franken so hoch waren die
direktinvestitionen und russlands auf
der krim 4 milliarden franken kostete
alleine der bau dieser brücke zwischen
der annektierten creme und dem
südrussischen festland hinzukommen
subventionen in die infrastruktur und
die sozialversicherungen der halbinsel
ein ende von moskaus subventionen ist
nicht in sicht
je länger die aktuelle situation anhält
umso stärker sind die negativen
auswirkungen für die russische
wirtschaft und umso höher der preis
fünf jahre nach der annexion fällt die
politische und wirtschaftliche bilanz
für russland ernüchternd bis verheerend
aus die rechnung bezahlt die bevölkerung
eppelborn versuchen wir uns mal die
sache aus der lage russlands zu
rationalisieren es ist sehr kostspielig
es kostet menschenleben es ist ein krieg
was ist die motivation für russland
gebiete die nicht zum staatsgebiet
gehören gewaltsam an sich zu nehmen zu
annektieren und dann auch noch die
bevölkerung zu russen zu machen
ursprünglich hatte der krieg in der
ukraine fast nichts mit der ukraine
selbst zu tun sondern fast nur mit putin
und seinem wunsch an der macht zu
bleiben
es ist eine längere geschichte aber kurz
gesagt legitimierte sich putin in den
ersten jahren als präsident mit dem
argument ich mag verrückt sein ich mag
indikator sein aber immerhin geht es
euch danken immer besser das traf auf
seine ersten zwei amtszeiten zu doch
jetzt stellt es nicht mehr
die wirtschaftliche situation
verbesserte sich nicht für alle
vor allem nicht für die bevölkerung in
den provinzen daher kommt er nun mit
einem anderen argument dass ungefähr so
lautet ich berge ruft aber immerhin
mache ich russland wieder los russland
wird ein großes land wir sind wichtig
auf der weltbühne zu erobern oder zu
kontrollieren verstärkte dieses argument
massiv es war auch aus einem anderen
grund wichtig denken sie daran was die
ukraine für die russen repräsentiert sie
ist eine verlorene provinz ehemaliges
hoheitsgebiet dass sie pro europäisch
geworden ist und eine demokratie werden
könnte ist sehr bedrohlich für das
russische system eine herausforderung
wenn ukraine demokraten europa sein
können warum nicht auch wissen putin
befürchtet einen ähnlichen aufstand wie
wir ihn 2014 in kiew beobachtet haben
daher muss er auf diese weise kunden
dass er dagegen ist also es gibt auch
eine geostrategische geopolitische
komponente die auch mit der
geographischen lage zu tun wir schauen
was noch mal kurz auf der karte an damit
wir wissen wovon sie reden
erst mal wie groß dieses land ist das
größte land europas lange grenze zu
russland und der russische argument war
eben auch dass man sagt man will den
sicherheit
aspekt betonen insbesondere in der krim
dass man sagt wir fühlen uns bedroht
durch die ausweitung auch das
einflussgebiet der nato nach osten
dass sich russland von einer ausweitung
der nato bedroht fühlt war schon immer
lächerlich gleichzeitig mit der
erweiterung der nato aus ehemaligen
staaten des warschauer paktes zogen die
usa truppen aus europa ab russland weiß
dass die nato ein verteidigungsbündnis
ist es weiß auch dass sie nie einen
kampf macht sein und russland einnehmen
könnte das ist eine strategie der putin
regierung die sie ständig anwendet sie
ist für putin ein weiteres argument dass
er an der macht bleiben muss vergessen
sie nicht er ist ein undemokratischer
diktator der keine öffentliche
unterstützung genießt oder sich der nie
sicher sein kann
deshalb muss ihr den russen ständig
argumente liefern warum er an der macht
bleiben muss sie haben etwas sehr
interessantes gesagt in ihrer antwort
nämlich dass es eine art größere vision
gibt die dem russischen volk verkauft
wird nämlich eine etablierung eine
wiederherstellung des einflusses
gebietes der ehemaligen sowjetunion und
viele fürchten dass die ukraine in
diesem sinne nur ein erster schritt es
ein signal für eine breitere
expansionspolitik natürlich diese idee
den ukrainern russische pässe zu geben
da wiederholt sich etwas dass die russen
schon einmal getan haben als die
russische pässe an die bewohner der von
georgien abtrünnigen provinzen vergaben
so verteidigten sie ihr eindringen wir
müssten russische bürger retten was in
der ukraine passiert ist tatsächlich ein
weiterer schritt in einem prozess der
bereits im gang ist
natürlich wird die sowjetunion nicht als
ganzes wieder auferstehen
aber russland will sich wieder als
wichtiger geopolitischer spieler
etablieren und das ist ganz klar
teil von putins rechtfertigung von
seiner legitimierung
damit sind wir schon eigentlich beim
charakter ihres projektes das eine art
kontinuität der russischen geschichte
der geschichte im ostblock allgemein
bespricht ja mein der trilogie
geschrieben über die geschichte des
stalinistischen total
tourismus das erste buch ging über den
gulag die vernichtung und arbeitslager
in russland das zweite über die
ausbreitung des eisernen vorhanges in
den staaten des warschauer paktes und
das dritte das jetzt erschienen ist ein
buch über den roten hunger über stadions
krieg gegen die ukraine wie sie es
nennen eine hungersnot 19 33 die vier
millionen opfer forderte ist das
eigentlich richtig geschrieben diese
drei extrem beeindruckenden büchern dass
sie einst sind und dass sie eine
kontinuität der geschichte der
wahrnehmung bis heute auch aufzeigen
wollen
ich denke es gibt wichtige unterschiede
zwischen dem heutigen russland und der
sowjetunion
alles ist genau gleich diese bücher sind
wie sie sagen als eine art trilogie
gedacht denn in allen versuchte ich zu
verstehen was der sowjetischen
totalitarismus war und wie er
funktioniert
ich denke der heutige russische staat
will dieses modell nicht eins zu eins
wiederholen denn es schlug letzten endes
viel aber russland versucht davon zu
lernen und ähnliche maßnahmen umzusetzen
und sehr oft sind mir ihre taktiken
vertraut als zb die rosen die kim
einnahmen hatte ich gerade dieses buch
der eiserne vorhang fertiggestellt ich
sah die invasion und dachte hätte ich
das doch gesehen bevor ich das buch
geschrieben habe
denn wie die russen die creme besetzten
die armee soldaten trugen keine uniform
niemand verstand was genau passierte
russische soldaten gaben sich als
ukrainische soldaten aus genau das
gleiche war 1944 in polen passiert
das aktualisierte kgb drehbuch von 1944
45 ich dachte jetzt verstehe ich es
besser
ich wünschte ich hätte das früher
gesehen auch sie sich lokaler
krimineller banden bedienten und mit
gewissen leuten zusammenarbeiteten um
auf der krim eine neue elite
heranzubilden und die alte loszuwerden
genau das taten sie in mitteleuropa vor
über 60 jahren eine weise kontinuität zu
verschleiern besteht ja darin dass man
sich nicht erinnert und keine
erinnerungsarbeit leistet ihr werk ist
auch deswegen so eindrucksvoll weil man
in russland selbst und in der
sowjetunion
sehr lange sich eine erinnerung dieser
schrecken verweigert hat dass es also
gar nicht so etwas gab was man in
deutschland beispielsweise
vergangenheitsbewältigung
erinnerungsarbeit gab in bezug auf diese
verbrechen zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
in den späten 1980 er jahren während der
historiker sprach man über die
vergangenheit
aber als ich in den 90er jahren viel in
russland umher reiste hatte die dortige
bevölkerung diesbezüglich eine fast
negative halten es hieß in den 80er
jahren haben wir über all das diskutiert
und jetzt herrscht hier wirtschaftliches
chaos alles schlug fehl
es kam auch fast sofort das gefühl auf
wir sind vielleicht kein großes programm
aber wir wollen nicht mehr hören dass
das alte regime schlecht es gibt den
wunsch eine positive lektion aus der
russischen geschichte in die gegenwart
hinüberzuretten versteht dass etwas vom
wichtigsten was er getan hat ist die
erinnerung an den großen sieg von 19.45
wieder aufleben zu lassen
durch alljährlichen feierlichkeiten in
moskau mit soldaten in sowjetischen
uniformen die sowjetische flagge tragen
da wird die kontinuität also sehr betont
durchaus aber es ist ein sieger
bestimmtes stück vergangenheit
sie sprechen nicht über die gulags oder
die massenmorde sondern über jeden sieg
über halb europa über jenen moment des
imperialen triumphes diesen versuch
putin wieder aufleben zu lassen
die negativen aspekte sind kein thema
vielleicht haben sie bemerkt dass in
jüngster zeit sogar italien wieder als
held aufersteht
in der erinnerung vieler russen ist er
wieder eine große figur
es gibt also einer selektiven zugang zu
der geschichte des stalinismus
ich muss sagen wenn man ihre bücher
liest dann sind das bücher die etwas mit
einem machen
das sind transformative lese erfahrungen
weil das leid und die konzentrierte
erzeugung dieses leides so schmerzhaft
ist es nach zu verlesen es zu lesen
nachzuvollziehen man fragt sich wie das
für jemanden sein muss der diese bücher
schreibt der 25 jahre lang sich mit der
geschichte konzentriert erzeugten
staatlichen lights beschäftigt hat
es ist schwierig und ich bin damit in
verschiedenen zeiten unterschiedlich
umgegangen als bruch der wohl ab schrieb
ich als meine kinder sehr klein waren
ich arbeite daran schaut aus dem fenster
sahen raus nur kleine kinder spielen und
dachte ich habe unglaubliches glück
durch meine arbeit schätzte ich die welt
in der wir heute leben mehr die
heiligkeit des lebens
ja und wie glücklich wir uns schätzen
können dass wir in diesem unglaublichen
moment der geschichte leben wir haben
frieden und demokratie und keinen krieg
das hatte also eine positive wirkung auf
die bücher der usa und der eiserne
vorhang sind zudem voller geschichten
von menschen die ihre traumata zu
bewältigen suchen die versuchen
zurückzuschlagen zu protestieren oder
sich mental damit auseinanderzusetzen
daher gibt es in beiden büchern viele
positive geschichten am schwersten tat
ich mich mit dem buch über die
ukrainische hungersnot das eben auf
deutsch erschienen ist
denn in diesem buch geht es darum dass
oft ungebildete bauern mit ihren kindern
verhungerten ein schreckliches
schwieriges thema ich kann nicht so tun
als ob
dem kann man nichts positives abringen
da muss man durch man muss es erzählen
als eine art warnen der erinnerung das
kann ein solches regime richten
vielleicht sollte man noch mal genau
sagen worum es da geht der holodomor wir
in ukraine heißt ist eine erfahrung
eines hunger todes von etwa vier
millionen menschen bin es binnen eines
jahres des winters und frühlings hat 32
19 33 4 millionen menschen verhungern
innerhalb von wenigen monaten durch eine
erzogene kollektivierung der
landwirtschaft durch den stalinismus
wichtig ist zu verstehen dass der
holodomor nicht nur durch die
zwangskollektivierung verursacht wurde
sondern durch teams von polizisten und
parteiaktivisten die von haus zu haus
linien und lebensmittel beschlagnahmt
man nahm den bauen buchstäblich das
essen nicht manchmal alles was sie
hatten ihre kühe und schafe ihre
getreidevorräte das geschah nicht
versehentlich auf grund schlechter
politischer maßnahmen sondern war
vorsätzlicher massenmord das muss man
verstehen
deswegen ist auch den krieg gegen die
ukraine weil es eine ganz gezielte er
seine zur auslöschung der bevölkerung
war genau es war eine gezielte maßnahme
die diese auswirkungen hatte der
holodomor war teil einer größeren
hungersnot in der sowjetunion die auch
kasachstan betraf wo ebenfalls durch
gezielte politik über eine million
menschen umkamen
aber wissen sie für stalin spielte die
ukraine gewisser hinsicht die gleiche
rolle wie viel putin eine historische
analogie stalin sah die ukraine als
problem
es gab dort 19 18 während des
bürgerkriegs einen großen anti
bolschewistischen aufstand und nach dem
1920 die kollektivierung begann kam es
zu einem weiteren massiven
bauernaufstand stalin fürchtete ständig
dass diese unruhen in der ukraine sich
auf russland auf moskaus wird und
dadurch wie während des bürgerkriegs
fremde truppen ins land gelangen könnten
ähnlich empfindet auch putin die ukraine
was dort geschieht könnte auf moskau
überschwappen was dort schiff läuft
könnte auch russland treffen
die ukraine hat diese rolle als
störfaktor in den letzten 100 jahren
immer wieder gespielt
es war aber natürlich auch eine
kornkammer die dem russischen
geschrieben sie werde schon geschrieben
die er sollte das heißt ein
rohstofflager und als solches wohl es
auch angesehen das heißt bevölkerung
selbst war ein instrument ell gesehen
sie soll etwas besorgen
aber sie musste dafür nicht eigentlich
akzeptieren oder eigenständig sein ja
genau
schon lenin war überzeugt wir brauchen
die ukraine ohne sie werden wir
verhungern natürlich verstand er besser
als alle anderen das vor allem
lebensmittelknappheit die
bolschewistische revolution ausgelöst
hatte
daher hatte die sowjetunion schon immer
eine obsession bezüglich der ukraine
was die zerstörung der landschaft
während des holodomor betrifft ist es
wichtig daran zu erinnern dass die
umgekommenen ukraine an einigen orten
durch großen und anderenorts durch
umgesiedelte ukraine ersetzt wurden
denn man war auf das getreide angewiesen
aber man hatte immer große angst vor
diesen aufrührerischen bauern und wollte
sich dagegen warten wie wichtig würden
sie sagen in einem heutigen ukrainischen
nationalbewusstsein ist die erfahrung
wir kennen ja länder oder auch völker
wie zb das israelische volk für die
dieser ausschuss erfahrung konstitutiv
geworden ist wichtig zentral für das
selbstverständnis
würden sie sagen das ist für das
ukrainisch nationalbewusstsein heute
vergleichbar diese erfahrung des hungers
tatsächlich war die erste
auseinandersetzung mit dem polo der in
den späten 1980 er und frühen 90er
jahren eine art offenbarung für die
ukraine
es war der moment in dem sich die nation
zu konsolidieren begann und der
widerstand gegen die sowjetunion wuchs
daher war diese auseinandersetzung
extrem wichtig die holodomor ist auch
wichtig weil die ukraine verschiedene
trauma dadurch liebt den krieg
säuberungsaktionen den holocaust
verschiedenste traumata aber der
holodomor vereint die menschen mehr als
dass er sie spaltet die prämie haben
sehr unterschiedliche erinnerungen an
den zweiten weltkrieg
es gab einem nationalen aufstand während
des kriegs darüber denken die ukraine
unterschiedlich doch der holodomor ist
eine vereinigung tragödie
interessanterweise habe ich aber in den
letzten vier oder fünf jahren den
eindruck gewonnen er weniger raum ein
als in den 1990 er jahre
da nun ukrainian richtiger staat ist und
gegen russland um seine existenz kämpft
ist die thematisierung der vergangenheit
weniger wichtig eine ironische folge von
putins einmarsch in der ukraine ist dass
dadurch ein vorher nicht existierendes
bewusstsein für die nationale identität
geweckt wurde dass die menschen vereint
auch russisch sprechender ukraine und
zur wahl von vilimsky zurückzukehren
ein wichtiger aspekt ist dass ihr
russisch spricht dann muttersprache ist
russisch aber er versteht sich als
ukraine und die ukrainer sehen ihn als
einen der ihren
es gibt inzwischen viele russisch
sprechender ukraine die sich als ukraine
verstehen
das heißt eine folge des kriegs
interessante sie sagen das ist ein
russischsprachiger ukraine das könnte
man sagen es für putin eigentlich eine
art alptraum bei der in der lage ist in
der sprache und mit dem heinz russland
zu adressieren wie es davor nicht der
fall war
ja ich denke putin machte einen fehler
als er in der ukraine einmarschierte er
gehe davon aus dass ukraine die russisch
sprechen auch grossen st doch das stimmt
nicht
ein großer teil der russischsprachigen
bewohner sind ukraine ukraine ist ein
zweisprachiges land wer in kiew
öffentliche veranstaltungen behindert
erlebt dass die leute zwischen russisch
und ukrainisch hin und her switchen und
sich in beiden sprachen zu hause fühlen
alle haben sich inzwischen daran gewöhnt
wie in der schweiz
aber viele europäer haben putins
behauptung übernommen
dass die russisch sprechenden ukraine
großen sein was natürlich nicht stimmt
sie sehen sich immer mehr als ukraine
für einige war das schon immer so es
gibt russisch schreiben der
schriftsteller die sich als ukraine
verstehen viele russisch sprechende
sehen sich als teil des landes das hat
sich vor allem in den letzten paar
jahren herauskristallisiert
innerlich ist dass da eine innere
energie und flamme brennt da sind jetzt
noch mal ein stück zurückgehen als
amerikanerin als westeuropäer in unserer
generation denkt man wenn man an die
geschichte des totalitarismus denkt
eigentlich zunächst an nazi deutschland
wie kommt eine amerikanerin unsere
generation dazu ihr leben aus washington
zunächst aus diesen verbrechen als
forscherin zu widmen was war da die
innere motivation gab es ein auslösendes
ereignis zu sagen ich kann nur ganze
puzzle teile zusammenfügen
ich denke auslöser war dass ich 19 89
das glück hatte als junge journalistin
in warschau zu arbeiten und mitzuerleben
dass das system zusammenbrach
als das passierte begann ich mich
natürlich zu fragen warum wie sie sich
erinnern samen 19 89 den mauerfall
voraus natürlich war die situation
schrecklich
man war überzeugt dass die mauer fallen
und die leute die grenze zwischen ost-
und west-berlin überschreiten würden
aber wie war es so weit gekommen
das begann ich mich zu fragen und
entdeckt eine große lücke in meiner
bildung
ich merkte dass ich nicht viel darüber
wusste ich hatte zwar einige vorlesungen
besucht aber ich spürte die geschichte
der ur lag's nicht so stark wie die
geschichte der nazi lager über die filme
gesehen und romane gelesen hatte und so
weiter mir war als fehle eine wichtige
hälfte der geschichte und diese
verdiente es entdeckt zu werden
zudem waren die 19 90 er jahre was
vielleicht einige zuschauer kaum glauben
können eine aufregende entdeckung zeit
bezüglich der russischen archive ich
stieß auf dinge die wahrscheinlich noch
keiner gelesen hatte zumindest niemand
aus den usa oder aus westeuropa und da
war dieses gefühl dass man etwas neu
erzählen
damit etwas sehr ursprüngliches tun
konnte also eine akademische öffnung
eine art frage aus dem journalismus
heraus man kann aber auch sagen ist es
auch ein interesse aus ihrer familie ich
habe gelesen dass ihre familie
ursprünglich aus weißrussland kommt und
dort wurzeln hat ich muss gestehen die
tatsache dass meine familie von dort
kommt ist nicht so wichtig denken sie
daran wie us amerikaner sind
ich wuchs in den usa auf und fühlte mich
durch und durch als amerikanerin wir
sprachen nicht über unsere herkunft
meine vorfahren kamen vor langer zeit in
die usa irgendwann in frühen neunzehnten
jahrhundert sobald sie dort waren
versuchten sie ihre vergangenheit zu
vergessen im sinne von europa war
schlimm vergessen dass wir sind jetzt
amerikaner ich entdeckte die verbindung
zu russland es war noch nicht
weißrussland sondern das vorkriegs
russland oder besser das
vorrevolutionäre russland ich war es
also die unsere wurzeln entdeckte und
dorthin gehen und meine familie war
erstaunt darüber also hat die
historikerin sozusagen die eigene
familiengeschichte entdeckt es gibt ja
wenn man sich auf dieses thema ein lässt
sich in widmet auch eine heikle zone
man forscht den totalitarismus im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert da gibt es die
show als die große auslöschung erfahrung
und es gibt den gulag und sowie den
holodomor wie geht man mit der gefahr um
das eine gegen das andere ausspielen zu
wollen
ich sehe dort das buch von hannah arendt
liegen
ich denke es ist sehr wichtig die beiden
zu vergleichen und darüber zu sprechen
denn es waren zwei riesige totalitäre
systeme wie gleichzeitig existiert
voneinander wussten sich gegeneinander
ausspielten und wie der historiker
timothy snyder es brillant beschrieb
teile europas lange gemeinsam
herrscher es ist also wichtig sie
gemeinsam zu sehen
im buch der tat ich das und verglich im
vorwort explizit die beiden arten von
lagern
aber wenn man über sie schreibt versteht
man natürlich auch die unterschiede die
lager war nicht identisch hitlers
obsession mit den juden ist nicht mit
thalys obsessionen vergleichbar
es gibt unterschiede aber je weiter wir
uns von dieser zeit entfernen so die
geschichte der zweiten hälfte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts analysieren
desto offensichtlicher wird die
notwendigkeit über beide arten von laden
gemeinsam zu sprechen es ist weniger
tabu als es noch vor 20 30 jahren war
noch als ich studierte war es irgendwie
tabu und ich denke das ist nicht nur
weil man in die geschichte der
geschichtsschreibung zurückgeht gibt es
schon den 40er jahren erste versuche
eine parallelisierung zu sehen und dann
erscheint uns von 51 dieses epochale
werk das an eine ganz neue wahrnehmung
ermöglichte von hannah arendt elemente
und ursprünge totaler herrschaft war das
für sie auch ein wichtiges buch in der
wahrnehmung möglicher parallelitäten
zwischen stalin und hitler system
es ist sinnvoll und lohnenswert diese
analogien zu ziehen
doch es ist wichtig sich zu überlegen
was das wort totalitarismus bedeutet in
letzter zeit haben gewisse
revisionistische historiker sich
dahingehend geäußert das wort sei
bedeutungslos weil es in beiden systemen
menschen gab die gegen die regierung
waren und weil es unabhängige
institutionen gegeben habe in hitlers
deutschland hat es unabhängige
unternehmen gegeben in stalins russland
einzelne regionen und andere unabhängige
akteure aber hitler wie stalin hatten
ein ähnliches totalitäres bestreben
nämlich nicht nur die wirtschaft und die
politik sondern auch die kultur das
denken der menschen und die bildung zu
kontrollieren und beide glaubten dass
dies möglich war dass man also alle dazu
bringen konnte gleich zu denken und es
war ein mögliches ziel alle
gleichzuschalten und jegliche opposition
auszuschalten
indem man solche leute in haft
er tötete oder einfach immer zu es gab
einen großen glauben an die propaganda
das was wir heute kennen das man so das
denken der menschen ändern und sie in
diese eine form pressen
in beiden systeme glaubte man daran wohl
keines dieses ziel wirklich erreichte
keines war vollkommen totalitären vor
allem in mitteleuropa wurde dieses ziel
angestrebt und es bislang das system
scheiße der immer wieder und es gab
ständig krisen aber der glaube dass es
möglich war die intention war das
wichtige was die beiden systeme
miteinander verband es lohnt sich das zu
verstehen und es gibt gemeinsame wurzeln
ihres gedankengutes im frühen 20
jahrhundert hält zum beispiel fest dass
eine große gemeinsamkeit das lager wesen
ist das lagerwesen für innere feinde mit
dem ziel der auslöschung dieser feinde
ohne dass ein totalitäres system weder
als stalinismus noch als faschismus
existieren kann sie sagt auch es gibt
eine aufhebung der grenze zwischen
wirklichkeit und fiktion die staatlich
betrieben ist es wird einer situation
als sorgt in der niemand mehr wissen
soll was eigentlich der fall ist
durchaus das sind zwei wichtige aspekte
dieser geschichte
zuerst einmal ist es sehr wichtig zu
verstehen was ein konzentrationslager
ist nämlich wieder ein gefängnis für
kriminelle noch ein kriegs gefängnis es
ist ein lager für menschen die nicht
gegen das strafgesetz verstoßen haben
sondern in irgendeiner weise nicht die
politische sicht die allgemeinheit teil
[Musik]
diesbezüglich hatten die lage in beiden
systemen ähnliche funktionen die bulats
und die konzentrationslager der nazis
warenlager für menschen die nicht
kriminell waren sondern anders dachten
oder aus irgendeinem grund nicht ins
system passen und beide systeme himmel
von den lagern ab ohne sie
funktionierten sie nicht ohne gulags
konnte die sowjetunion nicht existieren
punkt ist noch wichtiger denn es ist
etwas das ich wiederholt das überleben
beider systeme die davon ab eine möwe zu
verkaufen eine vision der gesellschaft
die nicht stimmte und deshalb ständig
bekräftigt werden muss in der
sowjetunion war es die lüge über das was
der sozialismus war wie er zukünftig
sein würde und was erreicht worden war
und sie mussten ständig lügen
gleichermaßen die nazis sie fügten
ständig bezüglich deutschlands problemen
und sagten die juden seien schuld dran
und so weiter lügen zu verbreiten und
das system so zu stützen war
charakteristisch für beide systeme und
wie sie sagten wurden in beiden systemen
die anhänger mit so vielen lügen
überschwemmt dass es für diese sehr
schwer war herauszufinden was richtig
und was falsch war die idee einer
objektiven berichterstattung die idee
neutraler beamter einer unabhängigen
rechtsprechung unabhängiger richter
nicht davon gab es in beiden systemen
denn all dies hätte eine art neutrale
quelle außerhalb der politik erfordert
es ist ja einerseits sehr verführerisch
andererseits auch gefährlich diese
kontinuität zwischen stalins und putins
russland zu sehr zu betonen aber dieses
bestreben eine grenzzone zwischen
fiktion und wirklichkeit permanent
aufrecht zu halten mit den mitteln
moderner kommunikation
das meint man doch auch im jetzigen
regime klar sehen zu können
das ist ein zentraler punkt von dem was
putin zu tun versucht weder hatte ein
riesiges system errichtet noch eine
enorme ideologie ausgearbeitet an die
alle glauben müssen
er hat neue wege gefunden um den glauben
der menschen in das was sie sehen lesen
und hören zu unterwandern
und das tut er wie sie richtig bemerkt
haben durch die anwendung moderner
kommunikationsmittel vor allem der
sozialen medien
ein gutes beispiel dafür ist der absturz
des malaysischen flugzeugs das sind
amsterdam gestartet war das über dem
stadtgebiet ak ihn abgeschossen wurde
das im osten der ukraine ab stürzte weil
es von russischen raketen abgeschossen
worden war
[Musik]
sie hat gut darauf reagiert bestritt es
nicht einfach ab er und die russische
regierung veröffentlichten ein dutzend
oder mehr unterschiedliche theorien ein
flugzeug voller toter sei in die ukraine
geschickt und dann absichtlich zur
explosion gebracht worden
oder ein anderes flugzeug habe versucht
putins präsidentenmaschine abzuschießen
du zur theorie
einige waren einigermaßen plausibel
andere überhaupt nicht wieder andere
verrückt und sie wurden über alle
möglichen russischen kanäle verbreitet
was war die folge wenig später brachte
radio free europe radio liberty in
moskau
einige sehr gute interviews der sender
fragte leute auf der straße wer hat das
flugzeug abgeschossen
die antwort war ich weiß es nicht und
werde es nie erfahren es ist unmöglich
es in erfahrung zu bringen
aufrecht zu erhalten ja genau das
gleiche hat russland nach dem
giftanschlag auf sergej skripal in
großbritannien
der britische außenminister ging den
verschiedenen erklärungsversuche
am schluss waren es 30 oder 40 versionen
so überflutet die russische regierung
das internet die medien mit millionen
verschiedener lügen um die menschen zu
verwirren damit sie nicht mehr wissen
was wahr ist vielleicht noch eine
kontinuität die man denken könnte ist
die dass es einen ausnahmezustand geht
muss es wird permanent das system von
innen und von außen als bedroht an
gesehen was dann auch zu kriegerischen
expansionen führen muss würden sie sagen
und das haben sie ja eigentlich auch
schon angedacht dass diese
ausnahmezustand auch in der ukraine in
gewisser weise erzeugt werden sollte
indem man einen krieg
erzeugt er das eigene volk mobilisiert
und wach hält ja durchaus diese idee wir
werden angegriffen das system muss sich
verteidigen ist sehr stalinistisch stahl
in spa neuer man muss nur lesen was er
in den 1930 er jahren über die ukraine
geschrieben und gesagt hat da redete er
ständig über die polen die
einmarschieren würden es gibt diesen
satz über pilsudski den damaligen
staatsführer polens wie sie schläft
nicht stalin hatte ständig panik vor
einer polnischen invasion für die
geschichte polens kennt weiß dass polen
damals keineswegs die absicht hatte in
russland einzumarschieren
italien hat eine paranoide idee von dem
was hätte passieren können aufrecht
vielleicht weil er daran glaubte aber
auch weil sie nützlich war putin tut
etwas ähnliches wir haben die nato
bereits erwähnt diese idee die nato wird
einmarschieren sie kesselt uns ein und
so weiter jeder der etwas über die nato
weiß und das tun viele russen weiß genau
dass die nato nicht in russland ein
maschinen will keines der nato-länder
hat diese absicht da wird ein mythos
verbreitet um den menschen angst
einzujagen wichtig ist auch was die
russen 2014 sagten als der ukrainische
präsident außer landes floh vor allem
abgehalten wurden und poroschenko die
macht übernahm
es hieß das war ein nazi das sind nazis
genau und seither bezeichnen sie sich
ständig als nazis was natürlich ihre
diskussion über den neuen ukrainischen
präsidenten erheblich erschwert denn
wenn die ukraine von nazis regiert wird
wie konnte sie dann diese sehr freien
wahlen abhalten die posco verloren
zudem wurde mit vilimsky ein mann
gewählt der jüdische wurzeln hat es wird
interessant sein zu beobachten wie ihre
propaganda maschinerie mit dieser neuen
komplizierten realität für jemanden der
sich so genau so schmerzhaft so präzise
damit auseinandergesetzt das totalitäre
systeme ihren bürgern aufgrund von
informationen die sie über diese bürger
haben können
thun kann muss es doch manchmal geradezu
schwierig zu ertragen seien zu denken
was man mit der information die heute
über jeden bürger aufgrund digitaler
medien vorliegt in diesem sinne
anstellen könnte die erschreckendste
heutige entwicklung ich rede oft über
russland denn ich beherrsche die sprache
und schreibe seit vielen jahren über
russland aber die erschreckendste
entwicklung in diesem bereich sehe ich
in china denn china hat herausgefunden
dass es durch die sozialen medien und
die künstliche intelligenz nicht nur
erfahren kann was seine bürger tun und
kaufen
es kann auch ihre gefühle und emotionen
kontrollieren und beobachten wie sie
miteinander kommunizieren
auf diese weise kann ich ihnen einen
kontrollmechanismus aufziehen den wir so
noch nie in der menschheitsgeschichte
erlebt haben und wir können sehen dass
sie damit experimentieren wie
schlimmsten heutigen konzentrationslager
befinden sich in der chinesischen
provinz xinjiang wo die muslimische
minderheit der uiguren zu hause ist dort
gibt es sehr große internierungslager in
denen oppositionelle die sich dem system
widersetzen festgehalten und überwacht
werden
es gibt überall kameras einmal mehr sind
die internierten menschen die als
schwierig und potenziell gefährlich
eingestuft werden und deshalb gezogen
werden müssen
das wird unter anwendung moderner
technologie gemacht
künstliche intelligenz und unter
verwendung von informationen die in den
sozialen medien ausgetauscht werden
verstehe ich sie richtig dass sie sagen
wenn wir das laboratorium des neuen
totalitarismus in live sehen wollen dann
müssen wir jetzt nach china schon
durchaus vor allem auf diese chinesische
provinz china ist ein kompliziertes sehr
großes land bis heute hatte die
führungseliten keine totalitären
ambition särge nichts dagegen dass die
bürger ihre eigenen politischen
diskussionen hatten
sie gewährte ihnen eine gewisse
politische freiheit
solange man keine politische partei
bildete
das system herausforderte konnte man
sagen was man wollte
es gab keine versuche alles zu
kontrollieren was die leute sagen oder
denken aber nun geht es um eine tiefere
ebene
sie kontrollieren die ich nicht in denen
sie die verhafteten sollen sie versuchen
deine unterhaltungen zu beeinflussen
indem sie leute dafür bezahlen etwas zu
posten
ansatzweise sehen wir das auch in
unserem internet was sind botnetze und
gezahlte trolls die gespräche zu
beeinflussen suchen
es ist dasselbe auch wenn es nicht
gleich staat kontrolliert wird china
versucht die gefühle der menschen über
ein sozial kreditsystem zu beeinflussen
denn man bei rot über die ampel geht
oder den falschen tarif für die u bahn
bezahlt hat für diese dinge gibt es ein
sozial kreditsystem und wer gegen die
regeln verstößt kann nur ein bahnticket
mehr kaufen oder wird nicht befördert
das sind neue kontrollmöglichkeiten vor
denen man sich in acht nehmen muss
eine der beeindruckend sind auch
verzweiflungs reichsten erfahrungen wenn
man ihre bücher liest besteht darin wie
groß die macht des staates und wie
machtlos das einzelne individuum gegen
diese maßnahme war diese bauern in der
ukraine waren machtlos gegen diese
gewalt wurden zu verhungern ausgesetzt
konnten sehr wenig tun andererseits und
sie sagten es auch gibt es selbst in
solchen situationen personen tugenden
die einen effektiven widerstand
ermöglichen was ist aus ihrer erfahrung
das was eine offene gesellschaft immer
noch am leben erhält welche personen
welche form von resilienz wirkt
besonders man muss verschiedene
gesellschaften in unterschiedlichen
phasen betrachten die fähigkeit offene
gespräche zu führen
lokaler ebene auf betriebs- oder
gemeinde ebene zu organisieren
die fähigkeit über führungsleute zu land
ja es gibt im buch der eiserne vorhang
ein kapitel über widerstand
natürlich gab es in den vierziger und
fünfziger jahren in mitteleuropa keinen
richtigen widerstand
in polen gab es in den ersten jahren
bewaffnete widerstandskämpfer doch die
gaben auf aber es kann andere formen von
widerstand gewisse leute gründeten
alternative musik gesellschaft es gab
geheime universität unterrichtete sich
gegenseitig im privaten rahmen und in
fast allen diesen gruppierungen wollten
sich die leute ehrlich begegnen und die
lügen des regimes außen vor lassen
diesbezüglich beunruhigt mich die
heutige entwicklung
viele meinen man könne im internet
solche dinge organisieren indem man zum
beispiel einer facebook-gruppe gegründet
doch dafür braucht es reale kontakte
man muss den menschen eine andere art
von gemeinschaft bieten die real ist und
ich würde ein besteht in notverkäufen
button zu tragen haben also würden sie
sagen weil ich das reh formulieren darf
die macht des antlitzes des konkreten
sozialen kontakte ist sehr viel
wichtiger als alles was sich abstrakt
informations kreisen realisieren lässt
ich finde kontakte von angesicht zu
angesicht in diesem kontext unerlässlich
wenn man ein alternatives netzwerk
gründen oder der wiese andere werde
aufrechterhalten möchte sind reale
kontakte extrem wichtig würden sie zu
diesem widerstand mechanismen auch das
erinnern selbst rechnen
die idee dass es eine geschichte gab die
noch präsent ist die wirklich bleibt
geschichte am leben erhalten sie
aufschreiben verstehen und daraus lernen
in der gegenwart über geschichte
sprechen uns war auf komplexe weise
etwas habe ich in den letzten jahren
gelernt viktor orban ungarn zum beispiel
hat oft über den ungarischen kommunismus
gesprochen aber sehr einsam
im bestreben sich zu rechtfertigen und
ihn zu instrumentalisieren
ein komplexes verständnis der
vergangenheit aufrecht zu erhalten ist
auch wichtig warum wurde die sowjetunion
unterstützt
man muss verstehen warum dieses system
die menschen angezogen hat anstatt es
nur zu verurteilen und zu sagen wir
waren alle dagegen
denn tatsächlich war nicht alles heißt
die menschen im angaben von und russland
dagegen man muss also auf komplexe weise
verstehen was der kommunismus genau war
und warum er scheitert ich denke das ist
in jedem land wichtig weil sich von
jedem land sprechen sprechen wir doch
mal von ihrem heimatland den usa wir
gucken nach russland mit großer sorge
nach osten
wir schauen auch mit zunehmender sorge
in den westen und da gibt es ja eine
verbindung oder eine mögliche verbindung
zwischen den maßnahmen von putin und der
wahl von donald trump wie haben sie die
veröffentlichung des mullah reports
wahrgenommen um glauben sie dass es
jetzt handfeste möglichkeiten gebe den
präsidenten auf dieser basis seines
amtes zu entheben
einerseits war der mole report sehr
nützlich denn was nicht gebührend
geschätzt wurde waren - sehr
detaillierte enthüllungen über das was
die russen in den usa getan habe das war
nicht nur ein wenig facebook werbung
sie reisten durch die usa bildeten
gruppierungen und facebook gruppen und
zwar unter falschen angaben und
einerseits sehr rechtslastige anti
migrationsgruppen zu schaffen und
andererseits die wähler unter druck zu
setzen
sie gründeten gefälschte wife martha
gruppen ihren mitgliedern empfehlen
nicht wählen das war digital
aber es gab auch realen
es war eine gigantische operation ich
denke wegen der frage eines
amtsenthebungsverfahrens gegen schorf
wurde übersehen was die russen alles
getan haben und was für unglaubliche
verbindungen muller nachweisen konnte er
kennt die namen der russischen
geheimdienstagenten jedes durchgeführt
haben das steht alles in seinem report
was sehr nützlich ist denn viele
anhänger der republikanischen partei
aber nicht nur sie bestritten dass das
passiert ist
die zweite frage war ob sich kommt der
rechts behinderung schuldig gemacht hat
da es anscheinend nicht als seine
aufgabe das zu entscheiden
er wollte einfach das beweismaterial
zusammenstellen und die entscheidung im
kongress überlassen
diese schlüsse daraus ziehen
das nehme ich mir ein wenig übel denn
auch wenn der kongress weitere
untersuchungen anstrengt kongress und
abgeordnetenhaus werden von den
demokraten kontrolliert und der senat
von den republikanern tram kam angeklagt
das heißt vom abgeordnetenhaus als
schuldig erklärt werden
aber der senat wird ihn nicht
verurteilen was jedoch gemäss ubs
konstitution nötig wäre
wir stecken also gewissermaßen wieder
sackgasse wenn man nach den gründen
dieser einflussnahme fragt natürlich
kann man sagen jedes land hat ein
interesse daran dass ein führer gewählt
wird oder nicht aber würden sie sagen
das hauptinteresse von russland besteht
darin diesen nebel der unsicherheit zu
kreieren oder einen bestimmten
kandidaten ins amt zu heben dass wir
zwei ganz verschiedene interessen
ich dachte die russland hat ernsthaft
und rammt investiert die russen wollten
dass er gewinnt etwas hat der mona
report nicht geleistet er unterließ es
combs beziehung zu russland zu
untersuchen
eine beziehung die viele jahre
zurückreicht viele finanzleute in new
york gegen eine vermutung hinsichtlich
jobs geschäften wegen seiner zahlreichen
betrügereien und bankrotte bekam er in
new york keinen bankkredit mehr mann
hatte die nase voll
deshalb nennt man in finanzkreisen seit
längerem an dass er viele geschäfte mit
russischen geldern finanziert hat sicher
sind wir nicht nur schien das nicht
untersucht zu haben für mich eine
weitere enttäuschung aber dinge die
trump über viele jahre geäußert hat
lassen eine verbindung zu putin und eine
biegung des buddhismus vermuten
zudem wissen wir von einigen
finanziellen beziehungen denn 2016 im
jahr seiner wahlkampagne versuchte er in
moskau einen trump tower zu errichten
er war an geschäften mit russland
interessiert und russland wollte
geschäfte machen genauso operiert des
heutigen russland unter putin
man hält ausschau nach leuten mit denen
man eine leicht europe
geschäftsbeziehung angehen kann indem
man ihnen einen speziellen deal anbietet
so geschehen mit dem unternehmen bank in
führenden unterstützer der britischen
progressive kampagne
es gibt weitere beispiele aus italien
und anderen ländern
die russen halten ausschau nach
unternehmen die offen sind für solche
die listen versuchen dann beziehung mit
ihnen aufzubauen
anscheinend bestand tut schon sehr lange
eine solche beziehung
es gibt also ein längeres muster das
noch vor der präsidentschafts idee von
frank vielleicht schon da war
jump in den usa in russland was man sich
fragt es und das betrifft ja auch ihr
projekt es ist eine sache ein leader ein
führer zu haben der ein konkretes
programm hat von dem man weiss was es
sein wird und das andere ein führer zu
haben bei dem man nicht genau weiß was
das programm ist und dieses programm gar
nicht gibt das scheint der fall als
historikern was würden sie denn sagen es
eigentlich gefährlicher eine führer der
im programm hat oder einer der nur rein
macht
getrieben situativ entscheidet ich ziehe
das inkompetente und organisierte
möchtegern autoritäre staatsoberhaupt
dem wirklich gut organisierten
intelligente vor
trump ist unter anderem deshalb nicht so
gefährlich wie er sein könnte weil er
wie sie sagten von den meisten dingen
mit denen er zu tun hat nichts versteht
er fällt auf gut glück seltsame
entscheidungen wird nicht auf seine
berater handelt ohne besseres wissen
diese art von kompetenz und die
unfähigkeit die us bürokratie zu nutzen
wie nicht nur er selbst sondern auch
seine leute an den tag legen sind
bezeichnet unter anderem erwuchs im
widerstand aus eben dieser bürokratie
von leuten die zu ihm sagten nein
ministerpräsident das können sie nicht
tun das ist illegal
das steht auch wie müller report dass
viele leute um ihn herum sich weiter in
seine befehle auszuführen
das gefühl dass das system als system
als rechtsstaat noch resilient genug ist
und tram einzudämmen einzuhalten
bis jetzt aber wir werden sie etwas habe
ich bei tram unterschätzt nämlich wie
viel schaden er allein durch seine worte
anrichtet ungeachtet der gesetze die ihr
erlässt die sprache die er benutzt seine
art gewisse teile der usa in einer art
stammes metall i tät gegen andere
einzubinden oder die autorität
unabhängiger institutionen zu
untergraben und zwar nicht nur der
presse auch der jurisprudenz
das ist alles sehr gefährlich und kann
langfristig negative folgen haben
er ist nicht der einzige der das tut es
gibt andere republikaner und auch
vertreter der linken die es ihm
gleichtun
aber die objektiven neutralen
institutionen des staates untergraben
die als kontrolle der macht ihnen können
ist langfristig extrem gefährlich
genau das ist den nazi deutschland
passiert und auch die bolschewiken haben
diese zwischengeschalteten institutionen
immer da hast sie empfanden sie als
fiktiv sie verabscheut parlamente
richter die presse eine demokratie die
an solchen präsidenten wählt hat ja
schon eine schwächung erlitten sie ist
in spezifischer weise aus gehört worden
oder gewesen es gibt jetzt viele
menschen mit dem man spricht in den usa
die sagen wenn es zu einer zweiten
amtszeit kommt dann könnte diese
aushöhlung wirklich kritisch werden
könnten ganz neue prozesse in gang
kommen auch was die woche was den bruch
mit der verfassung angeht ist das etwas
eine sorge die sie so teilen
es wäre sehr schlimm wenn er
wiedergewählt würde es wäre eine art
bestätigung dass seine anti
konstitutionelle sprache bis jetzt waren
es vor allem worte und sein instinkt
institutionen zu unterwandern
erfolgreich sind
es würde ihm und seiner entourage
bestätigen dass sein ansatz richtig war
ich denke daher eine zweite amtszeit
wäre viel schlimmer als die erste und
sie glauben was den einfluss von
russland angeht wird man sich da jetzt
in zukunft zurückhaltend nach ihrer
erfahrung oder wird das konzentriert in
gleicher weise weitergehen weil es gab
eigentlich keine sanktionen in einem
benennen waren sie wegen der starken
russischen beteiligung an seiner
wahlkampagne hat sich sehr bemüht
distanz zu russland zu wahren
abgesehen natürlich von seinen äußerst
sonderbaren privaten treffen mit putin
in einigen war offensichtlich kein
anderer us-vertreter beteiligt nur
proteams übersetzer anwesend was sehr
seltsam ist wir sahen auch alle die
sonderbare pressekonferenz nach dem
gipfel treffen mit putin in helsinki
der trank putin mehr zu glauben schien
als den eisernen geheimdiensten sehr
befremdlich aber bis jetzt hat von putin
vor sanktionen verschont
dieses dieses treffens das ja sehr
selbstbewussten menschen rechts zeigt
und einen der nicht genau weiß wo man
mit seinem gesicht links
und noch eine theorie über die uns nicht
schreibe weil ich sie nicht beweisen
kann glaubt trump selber dass er seine
waren unter anderen der russischen
unterstützung verdammt deshalb ist er so
nervös und seltsamen putins gegenwart
das vermute ich aber sicher bin ich
nicht und natürlich ist er sich bewusst
dass er langjährige handelsinteressen zu
russland hat deshalb hält er sich um
diesbezüglich zurück aber das könnte
sich in einer zweiten amtszeit
dramatisch ändern um zum ende zu kommen
wir haben eine ganz großartige leistung
hier verbracht mir diesen drei büchern
die die ein wirklicher jahr geöffnet für
dinge die man gar nicht wissen wollte
aber doch wissen sollte meine frage ist
gibt es aus ihrer sicht als historikern
auch dinge an die sich eine gesellschaft
ein volk besser nicht erinnern sollte
weil sie zu schmerzhaft sind weil sie
gar nicht vergeben werden können
es ist eine schwierige frage
ich denke unter gewissen umständen zum
beispiel bürgerkriegen ist es hilfreich
eine gewisse zeit lang nicht darüber zu
sprechen was nicht heißt dass die
menschen sich nicht daran erinnern und
darüber schreiben sollten
aber manchmal ist es von nutzen etwas
zeit verstreichen zu lassen
spanien ist dafür ein interessantes
beispiel ich sage nicht man solle nicht
darüber diskutieren aber manchmal ist es
besser im akademischen oder privaten
rahmen darüber zu sprechen uns den
richtigen moment für eine öffentliche
diskussion abzuwarten
öffentliche diskussionen können sehr
sinnvoll sein
im nachkriegsdeutschland waren sie
unglaublich erfolgreich andernorts war
der eher von geringer öffentliche
diskussion über die geschichte können
manipuliert werden man muss dafür bereit
sein also nach einer latenzzeit sollte
man den mut finden sich zu erinnern
sie haben diesen mut gefunden dafür
danke ich ihnen sehr danke dass sie
heute daran
danke reiben und jetzt gleich sehen sie
den hollywood-star cary grant
die sie noch nie gesehen haben die
sternstunde kurz zeigt wie coming cary
grant und am 28 zeichnen wir einen
weiteren philosophischen stammtisch im
sud in basel auf sind kinder ein
eu-projekt fragt barbara bleisch ihre
gäste und sie wenn sie live dabei sein
wollen karten gibt es unter dieser
adresse schöne woche und denken sie
weiter
[Musik]